hello again we're joined in the studio
now by the Home Secretary amber rod
thank you for being with us here today
and if you would can you just fill us in
on the latest about the horrific attack
in Westminster do you still believe that
it was a lone wolf operator yes that's
our understanding I mean it's an ongoing
investigation and the police are
continuing to make inquiries around the
people they've arrested about his known
contacts and I'm sure we'll get more
information over the next few days and
few weeks but at the moment that's the
working assumption and over half of the
Islamist terrorists in the UK are
inspired by what they read online what
exactly is the government doing to try
and get to grips with that clear issue
with radicalize is yes you're absolutely
right
there is an onslaught of radicalization
propaganda online basically attacking
people trying to persuade them to join
the crazed Islamist terrorist groups
that are being offered out there we are
taking action we've taken down 250,000
of these pieces of propaganda since 2010
we're taking down 2,000 a week at the
moment and we have a unit in the home
office which puts out an alternative
narrative to tell people not to do that
to tell them the value of families of
Muslims to make sure that people don't
go that way but it is a constant battle
with the propaganda that comes out
against us a constant battle I mean it
almost sounds like a bit of a game of
whack-a-mole I mean do you think that
the actual companies themselves need to
do more Boris Johnson has said that
their efforts so far are disgusting well
the efforts have been inadequate I mean
I don't want to say they haven't been
trying some of them have at the end of
last year there was an agreement which
in fact Facebook participated in as well
changing the terms and conditions
whereby they don't allow known terrorist
extremist content to be put up but what
I want them to do is to act to make sure
that all of it's taken down not just
known terrorists content but new
terrorist content there's so much more
they could do and I think they really
have to take responsibility for the fact
that their sites their platforms they're
publishing enterprises are being used by
terrorists that's why I've called them
in this week on Thursday I'm seeing a
group of them to work with them to try
and set up an industry board to make
sure that we really stop this happening
I'm calling time on terrorists using
social media as their platform you say
you're calling time on it but they're
going to need a bit more than a ticking
off aren't they I mean are you preparing
two fine companies who are they're going
to get a lot more than a ticking off I
want them to be part of this answer
listen these are people who have
families they have children as well they
will be moved by what they saw this week
they need to take action and of course
I'm not taking anything off the table
but the fact is an industry grouping
will work better if we can get it done
effectively we have it already for child
sexual exploitation and abuse abuse
there is an industry board they do make
sure that they police sit together that
most of it is taken down of course
there's still some that seems to be
reported but it's quite effective if
industry do it themselves but this is
not not something that there's no some
average conversation here as if that was
saying this is me making sure that there
is a step change taking place the same
time though we've had this conversations
before they've been leaned on before to
try and do more you say that their
response has been inadequate isn't it
time to stop appealing to their emotions
and start appealing to their wallets no
I'm going to appeal to the making sure
that they realize that these terrorists
are using their websites for that again
and I believe we can get them to set up
an industry board but I'm not going to
stop at that I'm not saying oh well if
you don't agree I'm going to step away
from this I'm going to make sure that
there are alternatives there will be a
plan B but I want to work together to
start with with them because I believe
that they are more likely to have the
answers they're the ones that put
together the platforms they're the ones
who are have a lot of expertise in has
I'd like them to come up with the
solutions because this is a national
problem and a global problem they should
be part of the solution we now believe
that college mysterious en't a message
on whatsapp in the moments leading up to
that attack is it time to end end-to-end
encryption on those kind of apps
end-to-end encryption has a place
cybersecurity is really important and
getting it wrong cost economy and cost
people money so I support end-to-end
encryption it has its place to play but
we also need to have a system whereby
when the police have an investigation
where the security services have put
forward a warrant signed off by the Home
Secretary we can get that information
when a terrorist is involved there
should be no Pratap Singh called
terrible with end to end
you know it's not it's not compacting
compatible you can have a system whereby
they can build it so that we can have
access to it when it is absolutely
necessary but I want to draw a very
clear distinction here
I support end-to-end encryption as part
of cybersecurity for families for
banking for businesses it's important
but we can't have a situation where we
have terrorists talking to each other
where this terrorist center what's so
you want to and you want to effectively
build a backdoor then which could be
exploited by hackers as well couldn't it
well we've got it is it is absurd to
have a situation where you can have
terrorists talking to each other
on a formal platform and you can't have
a situation where warranted information
is needed perhaps to stop attacks like
the one we saw last week and it can't be
accessed I need to find a solution with
them to that and one of the cornerstones
of your other strategies is to prevent
scheme yet we try and stop
radicalization going on in communities
and effectively to stop attacks before
they happen it's been dogged by
criticism not least accused of
alienating the Muslim community the very
people it needs to get on side is it fit
for purpose print does extremely good
work I've been myself I went and saw a
mother recently in Leicester whose son
had just left out of the blue to fight
in Syria and she appealed to prevent
coordinators to help her and help other
members of her family
we stood the prevent program stopped a
hundred and fifty people of which fifty
were children last year from going to
Syria they do really good work they
usually stimulated and run by
communities so it's not something that's
done to communities but I do recognize
that we need to do better to sell it to
communities and I'm going to be looking
at how more we can do that to tell these
stories so that people realize that
prevent is above all a safeguarding
program to protect young people from
becoming radicalized at the same time as
well one of the key parts of the
strategy against terrorism is the police
there if you like one of the key weapons
in your arsenal against these kind of
attacks and yet they've been hit by cuts
of over 20 percent by this government
and I just want to have a look at
something that the police watchdog said
recently saying that it's hard not to
reach a very serious conclusion
regarding the potential
perilous state of policing potentially
perilous state yes you need to take more
responsibility yeah I think that he was
referring specifically to the fact that
they want more detectives in policing
work and about the recruitment issue
that they have there in fact the
evidence that we've had from the
policing over the past week has been
that they have done a phenomenal job
they have stepped up they have had the
resources and the people and the
information that they need to do a
fantastic investigative job we are
putting additional money into
counterterrorism we are pushing it
putting additional money into funding
more armed police officers and more
armed vehicles so we get a full response
we're making sure that we are putting
additional money into the areas that are
really necessary now I believe we're
doing the right thing in protecting
police funding as well
it's interesting you say they're about
more armed police should there be more
on police in Parliament well we will see
I think we have to be careful not to
leap in with an answer parliamentary
security is kept on to review all the
time there are armed police in
Parliament but of course as a result of
this incident there will be and review
in the normal course and we will see
because one of the most surprising it's
a probably generous way to put it
reports about this attack was that it
wasn't actually the police that was
stationed in Westminster who shot this
terrorist it was the personal security
of the Defense Secretary who just
happened to be there is that right
well I can't confirm who it was who
actually shot the girl shopping why not
because it's an ongoing matter for the
police to discuss if they decide to do
so but the fact is there are armed
police in Parliament if we need to
change the security arrangements for
Parliament it will done in a measured
way after we've reflected and reviewed
what happened over the past week so why
is it you can't confirm it because it's
just the facts isn't it and there's
these Rabine reports in their newspapers
all this week well they may have been in
the newspapers but we'll wait to see
what the police confirm okay fair enough
and I also do want to talk to you as we
end as well about the brexit yes article
50 next week now you've course that
famously described Boris Johnson in
those debates in the EU referendum
debates as someone that you wouldn't
want driving you home at the end of the
night now you're in a situation where
bricks are tears are driving at the UK
out of the
in union you must be quite frightened if
you've got your seatbelt on tight so
it's such a prominent remainer well I'm
happy to say Boris and I have made up
since but the drivers they see are the
driver of this car is to resume to
continue the metaphor and I'm absolutely
confident that we're going to get the
good deal for the United Kingdom and I
can tell you much to some people
surprised that actually the Cabinet is
very United in working together it's
true we had different views before the
cabinet was put together but once the
referendum resulted in the decision to
leave the European Union were all
working together to get the best outcome
so you're not nervous at all come on you
can tell me I'm not nervous but I don't
underestimate the challenges ahead but
I'm quite excited about delivering a
really good opportunity for the country
thanks